[Music]
she's skinny and white but boy can she
write
it's the book spawned by our favorite
angry blonde that's right cat's very
first book you can't joke about that
comes out tomorrow it's the first book
to have a spine wider than the woman who
wrote it
and if you don't buy a copy you'll be
dead to all of us so join us with us the
author and box of toothpicks turned into
a Woman by which
Tim
oh baby
congratulations on This Magnificent book
I want to say what's very interesting
about this is that anybody in the
building I.E Fox that reads the book you
know who reads it and who doesn't
because the people that contact you read
it yeah because if you didn't like if
you get the book and you read it you
have they have to call you about chapter
five yeah about chapter five chapter
five I don't want to get into it here
because it's basically about a
incredibly graphic medical emergency a
medical situation yes yeah so we're not
getting into it okay oh no you can talk
about it well I talk about a lot of
things in the book that I went through I
talk about you know being broken
struggling I talk about the nights I
spent on a bus I talk about breakups I
talk about my mom dying and then there's
chapter five yeah which is an emergency
ostomy surgery that I had in 2020 and
told no one about uh and was on
television throughout with the bag yeah
and the reason I didn't tell anybody is
because I didn't want everyone to get
all weird the way everybody's getting
right now
because I was already feeling weird
enough and I wanted to be able to joke
around about it and I felt so weird but
I realized that so many things in life
are like that tragedy-wise because of
the exact rules for speech that we put
in place to try to protect people in
tough situations it makes it a lot
harder so I just didn't tell people and
then I came you know to work and then I
Had It reversed and that was a I had
some complications there's a lot of
blood involved they won't get into
details but it was on January 6th
yeah I had a worse one than Adam
Kissinger I'll tell you that
you had a worse one than anything AOC I
know every every time I saw her crying
about it I'm like I bet I beat you
I can't even talk about what happened to
me on TV but you can read about it yeah
yeah she gets into great details yeah I
know that you're into that stuff
the Google the word cat said to find out
what you guys are talking about yeah
as I was being wheeled into emergency
surgery it's basically
uh and I have a reverse now not to brag
all my intestines are inside
but where any I just I you made me feel
better because you were like cat this is
your Vietnam
[Laughter]
you laugh about it and that was what I
really needed and I didn't want people
to be like oh no are you okay no
well I think I mean this uh the reason
why this chapter it fits so naturally in
with the book is because it it proves
the point yeah I don't think I I don't
know how I would have handled that
situation even though I'm just you know
a few years older than you yeah
yeah so I was on the phone with my dad
after it was a person he was like cat
you're 32 what have you not been through
and that's how I got the idea for a book
because I thought well I said dad every
tough thing you go through you're
automatically building a connection with
everyone else has gone through it too
but then I realized what's the use if we
can't talk about it
so that's why I wrote this book I want
everybody to be open to speaking and the
healing power of humor and then we can
also build connections with one another
yeah it's very good
and I mean
not for nothing but your a your book has
an index B I'm in it yes he is in it
yeah that's big news for me I know you
don't care
um any other messages I mean you have to
this book actually has jam-packed with
like research scientific articles
supporting your arguments about about uh
the the healing power of humor yeah I
mean it's it's scientifically proven I
mean everybody says you know comedy plus
tragedy or you know or like comedy
equals tragedy plus time except for the
people actually going through tragic
things right I mean people suffering
with terminal illnesses people who are
grieving they say humor actually helps
them in that moment and I'm so sick of
the view that speech it's speech versus
sensitivity because it's not actually
you can say whatever you want you can be
as offensive as you want but also speech
can really bring us together what what
is the look on your phone I'm just
thinking I'm trying to think what Joey's
thinking
I'm just doing anything I tell he's
going like oh congrats on the reversal
no I'm just gonna
I'm just kind of pissed because my bag
only had pee in it like
I remember like meeting important people
at Walter Reed the whole bag right
beside me this is
[Laughter]
can't joke about something is actually
being actively harmful to people and
it's a miserable person because people
who are going through things need humor
to heal yeah you're right you're right
all right yeah buy the book
I want you to get that thing the number
one on Amazon so we wake up in the
morning and it's like whoa yeah plus he
told me it would that would happen when
I was in the hospital it made me feel
better so don't make it a lie
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else